you walk you wanted to bring food into
the toilet what you can't eat is that
what it is no he couldn't he couldn't
get up from the table while eating oh
it's like you can't eat well no you
can't
have you yeah
[Music]
hey welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys we
have a careful girl here here
hello hey Anthony can I talk you outside
for a sec you want to talk to me right
now it's kind of [__] up can you turn
off the cameras cameras are rolling more
importantly we have Ron School
nah she's halfway to regular now dude
it's all good yeah you'll get that extra
love until you're sitting right here
yeah that's fine I prefer this seat
so um today on this off the Record
prompt we're going to talk about things
and hopefully we're in a relatable
fashion we want to make sure we're
always building a relationship with
people who listen and follow us and
watch our stuff but we gotta be
relatable we got to be vulnerable yes
let's be relatable I agree I agree with
what you're saying what [__] pisses
you off in life dude how much time you
got brother
this could be uh you just genuinely like
maybe because of your childhood you like
hate this type of thing uh anything real
[__] that actually upsets you when I
open the door for somebody and they
don't say thank you oh for real it just
inside I just turned into the Hulk what
if they don't speak English yeah even ah
good one yeah see or if you just want to
[__] pound their face in I just want
to grab them throw them out the door and
then you open your own door yeah I think
that's fair what if he doesn't what if
he doesn't say nothing and he goes yeah
that's right [__]
acknowledged me
that's all you need it
should have started with that
that must be that must be hard for you
though because you actually can like
[__] fools up like I have that thought
and I'm like yeah that's right
that's how you are with with uh that's
you with dance though what yeah what are
you saying you can you [__] pools up on
the dance floor yeah you can [__]
serve them up real quick [__]
flirting in the first place guy
I hate traffic
I know it sounds so stupid let's go
straight into the hot takes
when I'm trying to just do regular
errands and if I get on the freeway and
it's immediately met with like
we're not going anywhere I'm like where
the [__] is everyone going what the it's
[__] like 11 A.M yeah where are
people going right now hey that's
relatable 100 relatable or no is that no
that's 100 relatable yeah or it's like
when someone is like trying to do an
exit off the freeway or like oh they're
going up the street and they know
they're gonna make a left turn but they
kind of take way too long to get in the
lane that they're supposed to be in and
then the whole time I'm like I'm just
trying to get in the left lane I'm
behind them and they just decided the
last second at the green light that
they're gonna go and then by the time
they slowly pull up to the left turn
lane it's already [__] red and then I
get stuck behind the light you know like
that pisses me off that story angered me
yeah you know what I'm talking about is
that relatable or what yeah dude that's
cool I also hate [__] the
with the [__] speed clocker yeah well
I haven't seen one of those before those
guys could all suck a nut on my goal
save someone's life right now yeah they
gotta hit quota quotas is me [__]
yeah I bet you have to you have to for
sure if you're in the job everybody
watch out it's almost the end of the
month you know what I'm saying like
someone is getting robbed and you're
over here [__] clicking away
because they could do something about
the speeding they can't do anything
about like crime bruh people need to
speed a little bit more because people
are on their [__] phones driving and
people don't even hide their phone
anymore they're just constantly looking
like they they have their phone up here
somebody 200 ticket the punishment's not
big enough wait how much is it 200 bucks
that's not bad for for essentially being
on your phone every day that you drive
and getting caught like you know maybe
once in your life 200 bucks it's not bad
oh I have another one you seem to be
angry a lot well I'm trying to be
vulnerable this table is very angry but
I don't know if I'm related about it at
all or not you're like you hate it when
you make too much money and you save so
much taxes and your friends don't
[__] understand
freaking jerks I don't get it I hate it
when I know someone's job so I do it for
them and then they still suck so for
example cans no McDonald's oh McDonald's
I know what this is this is how it
usually goes down okay I go can I get
the Double Quarter Pounder with cheese
they usually go medium or large and I
usually go large and then they go what
drink would you like sir and I go can I
get coke with extra ice that's how it
usually goes out okay to save time it's
a rally to save time I go over hi can I
get the like how would you like sir I'm
like can I get the quarter pounder meal
large with coke with extra ice they're
like sure uh what drink did you want sir
I'm like coke uh what size did you want
large I'm like I already answered every
[__] thing you [__] speaker but
that's because I gotta go one by one
right they can't access like everything
no but the thing is I already made your
job easy if you would just listen you
could have just get oh okay
and then you're too fast it's your fault
you're just following soon enough
honestly that job will be gone anyway
it's good it's already happening they
have McDonald's and taco
on Mother's Day I went to this place
where you pick up Seafood like it's like
a like a Boiling Crab type of thing and
I went to go I placed an order on the
phone
I get there
the lady who was uh doing to-go orders
she's helping this other lady so I'm
waiting right the lady pays for her meal
and then she sits down
I go up to the the host and I go hi I'm
here for a pickup for Nick and she goes
this is
and she looks at me and just goes I'm
actually helping somebody right now can
you just wait and I was like I hate
attitude oh I was like bruh I was being
nice I wasn't being a dick and I just
was like hey I'm just here for pickup
just so you know I'm not I'm not trying
to pay already I'm just like letting you
know what's up you ever go like
you see these not even dude I just oh
that made me some because I was like bro
like I'm not sure I'm not pressuring you
that makes me want to take my dick out
and then just go like rub it on the
handle dip it in the shebang sauce
yeah start peeing on the floor and just
[__] splash the puddle
myself bro cause inside my gold oh my
shoes [__] up anytime I'm ordering
food or I'm dealing with someone who's
working I try to go out of my way to be
like extra nice and extra easy service
industry is tough though you know 100
I've been in it I know what's up I'm in
the service industry so I get it I mean
Johnny Rockets over here that's what I'm
saying bro and then for personal
training like that's very service based
as well that's true
um like when you go when you just talk
to a normal person and they hit you with
that you're just like yeah well [__] you
then dude like attitudes suck nobody was
there I was like you're not helping one
you're lying to me dude no you're not
helping that was my answer people who
lie but not only people who lie but
people who know that you know that they
know that they're lying to you
no but I also
under the same umbrella of like
inconsiderate people people who lie
um and also people who are just not
self-aware dude Colleen found the guy
who stole her car and she confronted him
like did you steal my car and he's like
I don't know dude as he's stealing it
yeah what are you talking about the key
United States you smell weird
I wouldn't know
huh you know it's something I hate
that's kind of super Niche is that um I
don't like when nerdy people talk to me
like I don't know what the [__] they're
talking about oh like pretentious nerds
yeah because I went to like a like a one
of those Japanese import video game
stories isn't that a compliment though
sort of but it's like because you're
like you're not as nerdy as me but yeah
but you you'll drop like a vocab that
you know is like oh I get it yeah like
there was there was this game like video
game store and then on the monitor uh
they had loaded up like a version of an
NES game called Ninja Gaiden that was
ROM hacked so somebody had like changed
the characters in it to be like stuff
from modern day like and you've done
that before that's I I'm [__] do that
and then um I walked in I was like oh
that's cool that they they've done that
and he goes That's a rom hack and he's
like no you don't understand it's a rom
hack where they take the graphical
coding and they I'm like no I know what
that is like I also know I also do that
and he was like no you don't
and I was like are you [__] serious
you get way more [__] than I do so it's
impossible with a beard like that yeah
it smells I was really trying to like I
was really trying to tell them like no
that's like something I've been in that
Community for decades like and he's like
can you let me finish can you let me
finish no no no you're not a virgin like
me somebody takes the graphical assets
and they look and he just kept going I
was like dude what the [__] man that
[__] happens to me a lot I think just it
really is because I don't look like them
so they're just like you don't you don't
look like I do so you don't know what I
know kind of deal you're not a [__]
nerd dude you're a poser yeah for sure
nerd poster underwear see it's called a
wedgie okay
yeah it's in my ass okay
how do you guys feel about a virtue
signalers
yeah
those are great does anyone like really
like them here yeah he's like
embarrassed to say he's like virtue
signaling about version yeah yeah that's
a rough one man yeah when it's
performative yeah I mean it kind of
always is right yeah this is way more
trivial
um but I do have something that always
throws me off like it's so fast and when
it happens I always like
it takes me out of that place and I'm
like is it being interrupted
is it
say it
uh it's more like his where
um when you meet somebody and you shake
their hand and they don't make eye
contact with you really oh I feel like I
did that too the first time I met you
did and you were [__] pissing me off
and I didn't know I'm really scared okay
so you pissed off really in the first
time now you know what it usually has to
do with like their comfortability or
like yeah or like they're you know maybe
they're um you know this always happens
with
other influencers or whatever right and
then like you go to like an event or
you're at like the club or whatever and
there's like a table right and then
somebody's like oh meet this person meet
this person so you're like kind of
quickly meeting people that are probably
also like they do [__] but maybe that
person feels like they're King [__] in
that territory you know what I mean so
like meeting everybody it's just uh
yeah
you might as well just not even shake my
hand at that point don't even come say
hi to me bro like if I put those guys in
my in a different category of my brain
than just yeah no just like like I was
like um like you're like a plastic bag
full of trash like I'm never gonna
appreciate it
when you walk into like Zoomies and
someone's folding welcome to me
it's like you get it that's [__]
annoying too
look at me I'm very forgiving on that
[__] because I need a skateboard I
remember when I was working at a sushi
restaurant right or a Shabu Restaurant I
had both back to back and every single
time somebody walks in yeah
but you do that like 400 times a day
every day for like five times a week
stop giving a [__] can I say something
though
as a consumer of those uh restaurants
when I come in and they go ishma say it
gets me [__] and it gets me special
it makes me feel as fast it gets me
and I feel
I feel energy it brightens up my day you
still say it you just don't look at
everybody all the time
I always thought they weren't supposed
to look
but I mean nothing might roll the [__]
wrong they're all over it maybe but that
is dumb when you like walk in a store
and they're just like welcome yeah like
that's freaking I stand there and you go
what
acknowledgment shows that you care and
the lack of acknowledgment shows that
you don't care dude shake my hand and
don't make eye contact me [__] that's
disrespectful or when guys this hasn't
happened to me in a while but when guys
when like you shake your hand and they
just squeeze your hand oh that's hard
yeah I'm like oh yeah dude what is your
problem sometimes I also feel like
they're just insecure or something yeah
no for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and also then I go yeah like in my
head I go oh yeah that's a like you got
beat up a lot probably there's a plastic
bag when they do that do you do this
I hear you or I don't
you know what's kind of annoying too is
when somebody makes a really big deal
about you not knowing a thing that's not
something everyone knows when they go
like they go like or they go like hey
you fight you don't know Rob Pearson how
do you not know Rob Pierce
yeah but it's like yeah but then like
it's not someone you should know yeah
Rob Pearson never heard of them dude
yeah exactly I know Scott Peterson I
know that oh is that the guy that killed
his wife pushed her downstairs yeah that
Scott Peterson dude
is it really yeah it is huh it is yeah
oh another one I [__] hate cell phone
uh dog walkers
oh when they're just like this oh bro
for dogs just [__] everywhere and
then they just walk away oh that's a big
problem you don't pick up your poop yeah
you don't pick up your [__] poop dude
that's massive yeah that making me mad
that's how diseases spread bruh yeah oh
these people who leave who who live in
an apartment and they leave their trash
right outside of the trash chute but
don't have the time to just put it in
the trash shoe yeah what is up with that
you go all the way there but you can't
do this they don't want to touch it they
don't touch it I think they should be
burned it's just in the room and then
the room is just the hallway
I actually love throwing [__] down
you hear the ging all the sometimes open
the trash bag just so I can make it more
secretive
did you get more stuff
this shouldn't ruin my day but I love
food I love eating out and I'm hungry
I'll like all right you know what do we
go to the restaurant we know is good or
we should try something new maybe try
something new and the food freaking
sucks yeah I'd say like one out of five
times it sucks
yeah I was like fudge man now we gotta
go eat again oh when you're hungry and
your wife's like you're like what do you
want to eat she's like I want to try
this new place yeah okay I'll say
anything and make you happy always love
love love love you go there it's a
[__] 90 minute wait and you're like
I'm gonna [__] kill you yeah and
she's like let's just wait and you're
like okay babe let's wait yeah we just
totally [__] wait one of the worst
things is people that do not pick up on
sarcasm
when you're being completely extremely
satirical and they just take it
seriously
yeah that [__] is freaking that must
happen to Ryan a lot yeah is it because
it's a [__] nerd guy again no just in
general like that same guy we need to
jump him it's like it's like when you're
like when you're looking at content
online or something and then someone
makes a really funny comment because
it's something sarcastic there's always
another guy right after that's like well
you shouldn't say that because and then
like everyone has to help that person
yeah and be like no that's like people
do that yeah you Asperger [__] but
that's my that's actually my favorite
part of those situations is reading all
the comments of people like getting mad
at that guy from making a sarcastic
comment like that's my favorite is it
liking them all yeah yeah and I'm like
yeah you're right this guy is a piece of
[__] he should have never said what
about people who talk [__] about a
specific person and then you see those
people and engage and they're like super
buddy buddy and nice and then just
that's called business baby
Hollywood that's Hollywood when you're
living in L.A I was telling Steve green
one of the funniest examples of that was
uh remember how Steve Green was like
talking about his [__] High School
play and he was like Steve is all and
the reviews are in it's a hot show
people love it like someone in the
comments was literally like why is he so
cocky about his high school show that's
high school that's not even that big of
a thing and like tons of people under
were like in disbelief that the person
really thought he was whatever that's
just level two sarcasm from that
commenter if it's like another lap
around yeah yeah it clearly wasn't
because they were they were super mad at
Steve
I understand anybody who gets mad at
Steve you're on that side okay it just
makes sense this was a really weird one
but
um I remember when I was young just
getting an argument you know talking
back to your parents and then you know
when you have them cornered on some
logic [__] that they're just not
familiar with and then the last thing is
don't talk back yeah or yeah because I
said so that was everything yeah or
because I said so it's just that you
throw your hands up you go oh I can't
win that's a hard one and you'll never
win you just have to take it
internalized and just go yeah but there
was a period of time though when you're
like trying to like grow up as an adult
in high school loser
um but you're like this is pissing me
off I bet you other kids like Timmy
doesn't have it like this with his Rich
parents you know you start [__] like
yeah really [__] up your own [__] in
your head so like that and it like
changes everything but then you have to
like grow up and mature you know okay I
guess I'm gonna do that to my kids yeah
oh do you know what else is whack when
when people jaywalk and they're holding
a baby
I hate that or they're pushing a
stroller yeah it's like you got a baby
and you're gonna get a jaywalk with all
these cars he's just sprinting across
yeah what I hate is uh when I'm going on
a crosswalk and there's a guy with like
a pet or a baby and I clearly didn't see
them and I almost hit them and they look
at me like what the [__] is your problem
you know and I'm like dude
I didn't hit you it's not my fault you
know that's what I hate I hate that
yeah because I was texting I was texting
the group yeah it was an important text
though yeah like I was like lol's lol
with the Z you know what's in what's it
like the deepest cut of this like what
is the weirdest thing that pisses you
off that probably no one can relate to
you it's hard because I think I know I I
know I have top I I have the top one I
just usually it's in conversation where
it comes out where I'm like oh yeah that
pisses me off because I feel like a lot
of things a lot of stupid things piss me
off that like shouldn't matter at all
and it has too much real estate in my
brain but I can't think of it right now
I think the thing that pissed me off the
most is actually myself and I hate how
much I have to pee I relate to that me
too I blame my mom I don't know if I got
OCD or some [__] but like I don't think
that's OCD you got a small bladder no so
like a bark on a small block
now before I go to bed yeah I already
pee right so I pee and then I go in bed
and I'm like on my phone or whatever
chilling watching some TV whatever for
like 10 minutes and I'm like okay now
it's really time to sleep
to get up to go pee again and literally
literally nothing comes out did your mom
always make you be like hey oh we're
about to go eat like go hurry up go pee
you're gonna be in the car for a while
yes and also my mom made me um I wasn't
allowed to use the bathroom while
um
pay for the rule while eating while
eating because she said she said some
Chinese proverb it's like um like you
don't want to put you don't want to put
money in the bank while there's a hole
some [__] stupid [__] like that oh my
God so if I had to pee or poo I just
have to scarf it down because there's I
can't fit I can't pee or poo in the
middle bro these made-up rules you know
you want you wanted to bring food into
the toilet
oh
nice you can't eat while she
cheating have you eaten while taking a
crap not like bring food into the
restaurant you just can't take a break
excuse me I need to use the restroom
like I can't do that no finish the food
right now and I'm like [__] genuine
you really wanted to bring food into the
rest because I was thinking that you
weren't allowed to do that I'm like yeah
most people shouldn't be allowed
yeah that's illegal
into the bathroom
you wanted to go are you eating in here
well a little bit of both